we're now a few months into the vaccine
rollout in nevada and while we're seeing
progress
there is still a lot of work left to be
done orkomana joining us live from the
convention center with a bit more on the
efforts to get more people vaccinated
orco
well brian according to the state's
vaccination playbook around 34
of all nevadans aged 16 and older are
now fully vaccinated many people
come here to the convention center to
get their shot and special vaccination
events are hoping to
increase access
[Music]
music and movement to celebrate cinco de
mayo this is las vegas festival
also including something special the
kovit 19 vaccine
i feel a little bit safe hosted by local
leaders this wednesday night event is
part of an overall push to get more
nevadans vaccinated the community
coming out in full force i'm very
grateful that they have that they have
this
you know i was so excited i came all the
way from the west side all the way
to here you know so just to get the
vaccine health officials hoping to get
the shot in as many arms as possible
over 34 percent of people have been
fully vaccinated but we need that number
to be a lot higher before things start
going back to normal in the valley
closer to the strip carmella corte is
getting her first dose at the las vegas
convention
center on her 16th birthday i'm really
excited because i can
get the vaccine i'm now eligible
and i think that's really important she
had covid last summer and knows how much
it can impact someone
now she's encouraging all nevadans to
get the vaccine just like she did it can
help
everyone like do their part to stop the
spread many agree
we all need to work together a little
contribution
for the betterment of air for everybody
again vaccinations are available here at
the convention center
as well as several other places around
the valley we have a full list of
locations on our website
eightnewsnow.com reporting live from the
las vegas convention center tonight
orcom